How's it going everyone and welcome back
to another video in our weekly profile
series. In this video, we are going to
be talking about an intraweek reversal.
So, let's get into the PDF. What is an
intraweek reversal? An intraweek
reversal is where we don't have the
reversal forming the high of the week.
And so, what does that look like? Here,
you can see with a bearish bias, Monday
expands away, and then we get Tuesday
consolidation. Wednesday is forming a
reversal with then Thursday and Friday
to expand. So, where does the
opportunity lie here? Well, following
the reversal on Wednesday or inside the
week following that intraweek reversal.
So, here you can see, what are we going
to actually look for? We're going to
look for a candle two closure or a
candle three closure even inside that
weekly candle after we've already
expanded away from the weekly open and
then looking to trade that move lower.
Now, what do we need to see first before
we can trade that move following the
intraweek reversal? We need to see an
hourly change in the state of delivery
inside that reversal candle. So, if we
have that change in the state of
delivery, then we can look for those
following candles to expand. So, this is
going to happen a lot where you don't
actually have that picture-perfect
pattern or a classic expansion or a
midweek reversal or a Thursday counter.
This is where it becomes a little bit
more messy, but this is the logic of
weekly profile. You wait for the high or
low of week to be formed or you can
anticipate that to have formed, and then
you're just looking to trade swing
points away from that level. So, here
you can see, it's a Monday forming a
high, and then Tuesday consolidates,
Wednesday forms a reversal, then we want
to focus on Thursday and Friday. But,
what if Wednesday also consolidated
here? Well, then Thursday would be the
reversal, and then we could look to
trade Friday. It's not always going to
appear the same, but that's just the
logic of it. You don't want to just try
to match these together. You want to
actually use the logic and combine it
with a daily and hourly fractal model.
So, let's get into some examples.
So, here we are in our first example,
and you can see price is currently in a
fair value gap here. So, we could look
for a reaction out of this area. Now,
here is Friday. We have some failure
swings on the low. So, we kind of want
to let Monday open up. Monday expands
away. So, this is showing us that price
wants to expand out of this area or form
a reversal. Now, I can look for price to
continue on Tuesday here, but a lot of
times following a large expansion, we
can get a smaller range on the next day.
So, here on Tuesday, what do we get? We
get a small candle two closure opposing
that. So, that tells us what? We're
looking for some sort of retracement or
for the previous day low to get taken
out, which is a new fair value gap. So,
we could be looking for price to trade
lower here into the next day and then
look to see if it can trade higher. So,
what do we get on this next day? We have
a candle two closure. So, now we have
Monday forming the low and expanding
away, telling us that we want to trade
higher. Tuesday consolidates, which is
not a reversal signature, and then
Wednesday forms a manipulation of this
range low.
So, with this candle two closure, what
do we want to go and see? On that hourly
time frame, do we have a change in the
state of delivery?
So, zooming in here, we do have that
hourly change in the state of delivery
and a new continuation that formed right
here. So, ideally, we would not want to
see price do what? Take out this low as
it expands higher. So, let's see what
happens.
And you can see, we get a continuation
higher, and then we get into the next
day here with a large expansion the
previous day. I can be looking for this
next day to continue as well, but I do
want to be careful as it could form some
bit of a consolidation.
And you can see, it's not as clean, and
it get It does get a move up, but it
comes back into the range. Let's go back
up to the daily chart. So, just to
review, what do we have? We have Monday
forming an aggressive move out of an
point of interest, showing us that price
wants to form a reversal in this area.
Then on Tuesday, we get a little
consolidation. Wednesday, we manipulate
that low in the consolidation. We have a
candle two closure, which shows price is
reversing on Wednesday.
That paired with an hourly change in the
state of delivery, we can expect
Thursday to be a continuation day, and
then we can also look for a Friday
continuation as well. You just want to
be careful following these large ranges
as you can get a new phase of price.
Let's get into another example. So, in
this next example, what do we have? We
have price reaching into this fair value
gap, and we want to see if we can form a
reversal point here. Right? And so far,
we don't have a very aggressive
reaction. So, let's see what happens
around these highs right here on Monday.
So, after Monday forms, what do we
notice? We expand right through them.
So, is this forming a reversal off of
this high or in this fair value gap to
trade lower? No. So, we could look for a
continuation higher.
Let's see what happens. We do get that
continuation higher. Now, we're in
candle two, three, four, five. This
would be candle six. We have two days of
expansion here. We could get a new phase
of price. So, generally speaking, we
want to let another candle form.
Here, you can see, we reach into this
fair value gap. Now, what do you notice?
This isn't the best reversal candle,
right? Because it's what? A candle two
closure that is bearish, but also a
candle two closure that is bullish. So,
if we go down to the hourly time frame
here,
the whole idea is we are looking for
price to form a reversal here. You
notice price opens, and then this is
just trading lower. Do we have a change
in the state of delivery here? We do.
So, if we go ahead and throw on my
indicator here, what do we notice? It'll
mark out that change in the state of
delivery. But, it's not very ideal
because you can see, it's a bullish and
a bearish model. So, this is where, if
you did want to frame to the upside,
you'd need to have some more intraday
confirmation. What do I mean by that?
Let price open, make a low, form a new
continuation, and then look to trade it
higher. So, let's see if we have that
intraday confirmation.
And you can see, price is not respecting
the area we want to see be respected.
So, it looks like it's going to fail.
Now, taking out the low, we'd want us do
what? Wait for a new daily closure.
Now, what do we notice about this daily
closure here?
This is a lot better because we are
doing what? We are actually forming a
reversal on the daily candle. You see
how much better this candle two closure
is versus this previous? Open, low,
high, close versus this was an open,
high, low, close. So, this isn't actual
reversal candle, and so what could we be
looking for? If Monday expanded away,
and now Thursday is forming the
reversal, we can look for Friday to form
a continuation.
What do we have here? We have a
protected swing. So, we have an area
that we have an invalidation. We don't
want to see price trade below where?
Right here.
So, we could be looking for price to
open, make a low in this area, and then
trade higher.
Let's see what happens.
It is quite choppy, but we do that,
right?
Now, let's see how we close, and we
close
pretty strong, forming a new protected
swing on the daily. This is where we can
have Monday form a continuation because
what is it doing?
It is reaching for those highs on the
daily chart. So, just to review, Monday
expanding away tells us that it is
bullish. It's forming a reversal down
here.
So, then we can wait for a new intraweek
reversal or a new swing point on the
daily to trade away from. Here,
Wednesday potentially looks like it
could have been, but it's not really a
reversal candle. It's a bearish
expansion candle. Here on Thursday, we
form a nice bullish reversal candle,
which allows us to look for what? A
Friday continuation. On Friday, we close
over, and then we could look for a
candle four continuation into the highs.
Let's get into another example. So, here
we are in our next example, and this
will have an extra scenario in it. What
do we notice here on Friday of the last
week? Well, we have a candle two closure
in what? A point of interest. So, a lot
of people ask, do you trade Mondays? The
only time I will trade a Monday is when
I have a Friday reversal or a Friday
candle two closure, which allows Monday
to be the candle three. So, I could look
to trade Monday here, and what do we
expect? A continuation, right? Off of
Friday's reversal. But, with Monday
expanding away, what does that telling
us? That this weekly candle wants to go
higher. So, we could look for a
continuation in candle four to trade
this higher.
And we do get that continuation. It's
quite small following a large range, but
now we could wait for a new phase of
price.
Keeping a bullish bias, what do we have
here? A candle two closure. So, we could
be looking for price to do what? Take
out its previous day low or reach into
this fair value gap. Now, as we let this
next day play out, it does take out our
previous day low, close above, but most
importantly, there is an SMT with RB
here, which allows us to treat this like
a candle two closure or treat it like it
as a swing point like that. So, with
that SMT, we now have Monday expanding
away.
Tuesday, Wednesday, kind of a
consolidation.
Then, I would be treating Thursday like
a candle two or a reversal, and I could
be looking for what on Friday? A
continuation.
Now, with this candle closure, I could
look for another continuation on Monday
because if this is candle two, or I'm
treating it like that because of the
SMT, this is candle three, and then I
could be looking for candle four to
continue higher. But, this is another
scenario where an intraweek reversal
doesn't have to form from a candle two
at a point of interest if you have SMT.
If you notice, this is still a candle
two, but it's not at that point of
interest, but it's fine because if we go
to RB at this same time, you notice that
RB is reaching into that fair value gap
there, which allows us to consider that
an SMT and trade it higher. So, here we
are in our last example, and what do we
notice here? Well, our monthly time
frame has a candle two closure. We are
trading lower here. And if we still
close below on the end of this month,
which we are, we can be looking for a
continuation in the following day.
You can see we've taken out a range
high. We have a candle two closure.
Candle three closes low. So, we could
still be looking for Monday to do what?
Expand lower as long as it remains in
respect to 50% of this candle.
So, Monday we open up and we do expand
lower. Now, this is where I want to say,
"Okay, well, Monday's expands lower.
That's candle four. I could get a new
phase of price here. So, I want to be a
bit more careful. So, I could wait for a
new swing point to form."
What do we get? We do get another
continuation, but we form these equal
lows. I want to wait for another day.
And then here we form a swing point.
Now, with this candle, we could look for
a 50% of its wick to be respected. And
what do we have below? Equal lows as
well as these equal lows and these
previous months' lows. So, we have a lot
of different confluences. Range high
taken out, expansion, retracement. We
can be looking for another expansion.
So, you can see Monday expands, Tuesday
also expands, Wednesday's forming an
intraweek reversal. So, we could be
looking for Thursday to get a
continuation. And depending how Thursday
closes, we can get a Friday continuation
as well.
Here you can see that area is respected.
We're closing below this up close candle
as well as below these equal lows. So,
we are very close to this previous low
and these lows here. So, we could look
for Friday to continue as well, which it
does and takes out those lows. So, just
to review, Monday expands away as a
continuation of Thursday's reversal
here.
We leave Tuesday alone as it's already
expanded a fair bit. Wait for a new
swing point to form. In this case,
that's Wednesday, which allows us to
look for Thursday and Friday to be a
continuation move as well. Now, an
intraweek reversal can form on
Wednesday, Thursday. It doesn't have to
be so picture perfect, but hopefully
these various scenarios helped you learn
it. If you did enjoy it, please give it
a like and a subscribe and I'll see you
guys next time.